لتبني اكبر واعظم بناء في العالم يوجد
طريقتان الاولى ان تبني اعظم واكبر بناء
في العالم اما الثانيه ان تبني بناء
متواضعا وتعمل على هدم المباني الاعلى
والافضل او على الاقل ان تفرح بزوالها
وفق هذه العقليه وهي العقليه الاكثر رواجا
اكثر شخص سعيد باعتزال هو
نادال صحيح ولكن على العكس نادال كان اكثر
شخص حزينا لاعتزال وذلك لان محفزه الاول
والاقوى على تطوير ادائه مشى فالنت يعرف
بنده
الدول تنافسا على الصداره كافضل دول
العالم في التعليم هي سنغافوره اليابان
فنلندا كوريا الجنوبيه وكندا
انتقيت لكم ثلاثه امثله مختلفه علنا نجد
انفسنا باحداها معكم سالي معاذ مدرسه
وترجمان محلف
[موسيقى]
الى من يميل الى طريقه الترس فرينينج وهي
الطريقه الهادئه اليكم هذا البلد الصاعد
تعليميا فنلندا فنلندا
تهتم كثيرا
بالانشطه والمهارات والاكتشاف الحر اكثر
بكثير مما تهتم بكميه المعلومات كما وتهتم
ايضا بطريقه التعليم التعاوني وهي عكس
التنافسي
فالطريقه التنافسيه والتي تتبناها امريكا
وبريطانيا مثلا
يعني ان هناك رابح وخاسر اما في الطريقه
التعاونيه فلا يوجد طالب مجد واخر كسول
لان المدرسه ليست فقط للتعليم بل هي
لتنميه الشخصيه والقدرات التعليم في
فنلندا مجاني ليس فقط في سوريا مجاني ولكن
التعليم في فنلندا يضمن وجود مساعد متخصص
لذوي الهمم وذوي المهارات او ال ال
الحاجات الخاصه
كمثلا صعوبات الحركه وصعوبات التعلم وذلك
لتامين مستوى عادل للجميع
وايضا هناك مواد في فنلندا مرتبطه جدا
بحياه الفرد فمثلا يوجد ماده تدعى ماده
التدبير المنزلي وهي موجهه للجنسين تعلم
هذه الماده علم التغذيه وعلم الطعام كما
ان هناك اسلوبا لتعليم الطالب اداره
الاسره والبيئه
يوجد ماذا تدعى بماده الصحه وتهدف الى
زياده الوعيد في امن الطالب النفسي والبدن
تنفرد فنلندا بماذا تدعى ماده المشوره
التعليميه وهي تدرس من السابع وحتى التاسع
تهدف هذه الماده الى تعريف الطالب الى
ميوله كما تهدف ايضا الى قدرته على او
تحسين قدرته على اختيار ما ينفعه في
المستقبل
الى من يقول بان الرجعيه هي السبب الاساسي
لايقاف تطور انظمه التعليم في العالم
اليكم سنغافوره
سنغافوره هي جزيره صغيره فقيره بدات
نهضتها من تحت الصفر في عام
1969 كان الناس في سنغافوره يستحمون في
الشوارع لكم ان تتخيلوا حجم الوعي
الاجتماعي والثقافي والفكري لهكذا بلد
ولكن بعد 48 عام اي في عام 2018 اعتلت
افضل
الانظمه التعليميه في العالم
طبعا الامر لم يكن بتلك السهوله على
الاطلاق
طالبه كثيرا بمساعدات دوليه وعادت طلباتها
بالرفض فاعتمدت على ذاتها
في عام 2007 انفقت سنغافوره سبعه مليارات
دولار على التعليم اي ما يقارب خمس
ميزانيه سنغافوره اما المناهج في سنغافوره
فهي ليست كثيره ولا تعتمد على كثره المواد
او المعلومات 30% معارف وعلوم 40%
اخلاقيات عامه و30% فنون ومسرح وموسيقى
تدرس سنغافوره الرياضيات بطريقه ممتعه جدا
كما وتهتم بالسرعه في الاجابه
تهتم جدا ايضا
بدمج
التكنولوجيا في التعليم
قدره ابتكاريه وابداعيه في التعليم فهي
تركز على وجود عده اجابات لسؤال واحد وهذا
يعزز التفرد والتميز اما التركيز على
طريقه واحده فذلك يجعل من الطلبه نسخا
لاجابه واحده
هو مؤسس سنغافوره ورئيس وزرائها الاسبق
وصاحب المقوله الشهيره ان تنظيف الفساد
مثل تنظيف الدرج فكر مليا لمحاوله رفع
مستوى بلاده مما كانت عليه الى ما هي عليه
الان وخلصت الى مجموعه عوامل منها اكتشاف
مهارات الطلاب وهواياتهم والعمل على
تعزيزهم كما ايضا اهتم
بالاهتمام بثوي الهمم ودمجهم في الوظائف
عمل علقه توفير انظمه تعليميه تهدف الى
تطوير شخصيه الطالب
تكامل تام بين مؤسسات الدوله لينتج عنه
نظاما تعليميا مركزيا مرنا ومتجانسا
في عام 2007 كانت سنغافوره افضل دول
العالم في تدريس العلوم والرياضيات ففكرت
كاليفورنيا باستخدام مناهج الرياضيات في
سنغافوره
من الغرائب
عندما توفي لم يشيع لا منزله ولا من سدره
سده رئاسته بل شيع من الجامعه كم هو مؤثر
بمرحله من المراحل
كان هذا البلد
اتعرفونه
نعم هو اليابان كان هذا البلد بمرحله من
المراحل بنفس مستوى
بلادنا الان اي في عام 1945 وهو عام
سقوط هيروشيما وناك زاكي ولكن سرعان ما
تطور هذا البلد لانه اعتمد على تطوير
التعليم لديه وعلى عكس فنلندا يعشق النظام
الياباني الضغط في التعليم فبعد ان ينتهي
طالب صباحا من مدرسته وما يتبعها من
عمليات تنظيف يذهب الى الغوكو الغوكو هي
مدرسه مسائيه تهتم بتعزيز قدرات الطالب
وما تعلمه في الصباح
وذلك لتؤهله الى المدرسه الثانويه وما
يتبعها من امتحان يقال عنه امتحان الموت
اقل ما يقال عن هذا الامتحان انه امتحان
صعب للغايه يهدف الى تعريف الطالب الى
الكليه المناسبه التي سيدخلها فيما بعد
كما وتعرفه على مستوى الاجتماعي وراتبه
اما المناهج في اليابان فهي مناهج ثريه
جدا فهي تهتم كثيرا بالفضول وتهتم
بالمثابره والضمير الحي كما تهتم ايضا
بتعزيز الثقه لدى الطالب فالذكاء والحفظ
مهارتين الاساسيتين لتحديد مستوى الطالب
كما تهتم ايضا بالوحده والجماعه فيتعلم
الطالب منذ صغره ان فشله بشيء معين يعني
فشل اليابان
اما الدقه والانضباط فهي ما يميز الشعب
الياباني ومنذ زمن وذلك لانه تعلمها في
المدرسه فاصبحت هي العامل الرئيسي وراء
نجاحه صدقوني يا كرام اليابان ليست كوكبا
على الاطلاق هي مجرد بلد
منضبط باخلاق وقوانين
الان ما المستفاد من هذه الخلاصات الثلاثه
في ظل الحاله الذين نعيش
في الماضي كان يقال عماد المدرسه استاذ
وطالب وكتاب اما الان فيوجد عنصر جديد وهو
عنصر الاداره التعليميه المرنه
والسؤال هنا هل نستورد نظاما من الانظمه
الانفه الذكر مثلا ونطبقه كما هو في
الواقع ضاله المؤمن
علينا النظر الى جميع التجارب الناجحه
والفاعله مع محاوله اصطياد التقنيات
المناسبه فالعالم اليوم واحد وبالتالي
مشاكله متقاربه فما المانع من الاقتباس
ولكن في المقابل هل لكل لكل تعليم اهداف
فهل اهدافنا هنا في الشام تشبه اهدافهم
وايضا لا يمكن لنظام مهما كان ناجحا
البقاء والاستمرار طويلا وذلك بسبب تغير
وتبدل المقاييس والمعايير عبر الزمان
والمكان فمعايير تحديد افضل الانظمه
التعليميه هما معياران الاول تناسبه مع
باقي الانظمه في الدوله وتناسبه مع البيئه
ثانيا عبقريه النتائج اذا ما دخلنا الى
المسابقات العالميه واستمرار هذه العبقريه
فمثلا
العوائل الراقيه في اليابان تبدا بتعلقيني
اطفالها منذ الصغر اسئله دخول امتحان
جامعه طوكيو لماذا
لان 40% من المدراء التنفيذيين الناجحين
في اليابان هم من خريجي هذه الجامعه رغم
وجود 300 جامعه اخرى
متطلبات التطور في الماضي تختلف كثيرا عما
هي عليه الان في الماضي اراضي واسعه
موقع استراتيجي وبترول اما الان تعليم جيد
تربيه مرنه وحره في الاسر والمدارس مراكز
للتدريب مراكز للبحث غنيه وسريه ونظام
تعليمي مرن اذا المطلوب اليوم انسان من
نوع جديد
المساحه الصغيره والعدد السكاني الصغير
الان في الذكر
مقدراتها تقارب مصر ذات المئه مليون نسمه
والالف كيلو متر مربع
من جانب اخر
لايجاد نهضه جديده
ومستمره يجب علينا التركيز على ما يلي
تدريب الانسان تطوير عقله والاهتمام
بالجانب الخلقي لديه وتحديدا بضبط الذات
فالعصر اليوم معروف بانه عصر الاداره عصر
السرعه عصر التكنولوجيا عصر الذكاء الصنعي
وعصر التخلف الاخلاقي ايضا ولكن اذا ما
نظرنا الى الاخلاق المرتبطه بالعمل نجدهم
قد يعتنوا بها كثيرا
امانه في الاداء التزام بالوقت
والمعايير مصداقيه بذكر المواصفات جديه في
العمل اذا لا يمكن ان يوجد تطور باي منحه
من مناحي الحياه بمعزل عن الالتزام
والانضباط
العوده الى نقطه البحث الاصليه يقول
الدكتور عبد الله الدنان صاحب نظريه تعلم
اللغه العربيه عن طريق الفطره يقول بان
افضل طريقه للتعليم هي باحياء الفضول
العلمي لدى الطلاب
وضرب لنا مثلا عن اسئله
المناهج لدينا فاسمعوا يا كرام هذه الجمله
كانت المراه تنظف منزلها بعد ان خرج
اطفالها صباحا الى المدرسه وهي تحني ظهرها
اسئله الكتاب ماذا كانت تفعل المراه الى
اين ذهب الاطفال متى ذهب الاطفال اي ان
الاسئله
مباشره ولكن اذا سالنا هل كانت المكنسه
طويله ام قصيره
نجد بعد الطلبه وبعض اوليائهم يقولون بان
الاسئله من خارج المنهاج ولكن اذا ما
نظرنا الى عباره وهي تحني ظهرها نجد ان
ساعد المكنسه كان قصيرا اي ان مناهجنا لا
تساعد على الاستنتاج
اما فيما يخص معركه تعليم التاريخ فلدينا
قاعده هامه جدا ودقيقه جدا تقول كلما كثرت
لدينا الوقائع سواء بالتجربه العمليه او
بالقراءه كلما كبرت قاعده القياس كبر
قاعده القياس يعني قدرتنا على استنباط
الحلول للمشاكل الماضيه والقدره على
تطويعها لما يتناسب مع مشاكل الحاضر اين
تعلم الثبات
تعلم التاريخ هو شرط للوعي في العالم
اما فيما يخص الجغرافيا والتي تعلم بناء
العقول الاستراتيجيه
فتعلم الجغرافيا يعني تعلم الممرات في
العالم وبالتالي نستطيع ان نشكل صوره عن
الاقتصاد والشعوب وكيفيه تواصل القارات
فيما بينها للاسف التاريخ والجغرافيا هما
احد المعارك التي خسرناها ويجب استردادها
اما فيما يخص تعليم ماده الرياضيات فاكبر
اعدائها هم بعض مدرسوها عندما قاسوا ذكاء
وغباء الطالب بقدرته على حل مساله ما
لتعليم الرياضيات
فوائد عديده من اهمها
اننا نستطيع ان نتحدث عن موضوع معين
باسلوب مجرد والتعليم اي اذا ما حللنا
معادله معينه فجميع المعادلات التي على
شاكلتها تكون قد حلت
الانسياب في الفضاءات الاخرى فتعلم
الرياضيات بشكل جيد يعني اننا نستطيع ان
نتعلم العلوم والفيزياء بشكل جيد ايضا
وبالتالي
العطب فيها يؤدي الى العطب
اما تعلم
المهني او الفني كما نقول التعليم المهني
والفني فهو هام ولا يقل اهميه عن التعليم
الجامعي وذلك لانه المحرك الرئيس وراء
اقتصاد البلاد اذا ما نظرنا طبعا الى
التنميه المستدامه وهذا يعني انه يجب
علينا تصحيح النظره النمطيه الذهنيه
الطبقيه للمجتمع
فاهداف التعلم هدفان الاول حمايه ثقافه
الفرد والمجتمع وامن اقتصاد البلاد
الخلاصه
انا ارى
ان العلوم على انواعها موجوده وتتطور ومنذ
زمان ولكن الربط بين النفس والواقع المعاش
والحياه هو ما يجعل لها نفع وبالتالي
الربط بين العلم بالمجمل وبين النفس
والحياه يتناسب طردا مع ما يعود على
المجتمع من نفع
فيجب علينا النظر بنظره تحليليه لواقعنا
تحديد مواطن الحاجه الاخذ من التجارب
السابقه التخطيط للمستقبل تعاون الافراد
وتوحد المجتمع من جهه ومن جهه اخرى نفسيه
ضبط للنفس ومثابره وسعي دائم وحثيف مغلفين
بالاخلاق ينتج عنه بذره قريبه الاثمار
التعليم امن قومي واستثمار ناجح ومربح
دائما فهل ادواتنا الان تعيننا على
التعامل مع المستقبل هل نحن نشكل ونربي
جينا قادرا على التعامل مع الظروف
المستقبليه هل ندعو ونحث على البحث
والتطوير والابتكار
تذكر لكل فرد منا دور منوط فيه القيام به
اذا ما اردنا الوصول الى مناط محله فسفرك
سيبطئ ويعيق الثمر والسلام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]